When do you think I should retest for microtoxins?
Mine were elevated, and we have done a lot to clean up our house.
What would this tell you?
Sure, you follow my recommendations.
You've done a lot to try to clean up your body as well.
So typically, I say six months.
Give yourself six months of treatment,
meaning detoxification from the microtoxins
and give you six months to clean up or investigate the possible sources.
And then retest.
What would it tell us?
What could you find when you do a retest?
Let's say you had elevated,
aquatoxin A, microtoxin for 10th.
And you do your investigation at your house.
Maybe you went to the extent of getting those petri dishes
and testing every area in a house and something was found
in your master bathroom and you actually did remediation
and you cleaned it out blah, blah, blah, blah.
And you've been taking different key layers to pull.
You've taken, let's pretend Michael pulled a pull that out of your body
and then you run the test again in six months.
Well, three things could happen.
Number one, it's much better.
So aquatoxin A went way down at your body
and nothing else went up and we'd call that a win, right?
But that would be a perfect case in area.
But that just does not always happen.
Sometimes you do it again.
And let's say aquatoxin A is down
but let's say microfintelic acid, MPA is way up.
What beads is going on there?
Okay, well then we know we have other sources of microtoxin.
You have to go back to the drawing board
and look at foods that you might be there.
Whatever things you might be drinking
that could give you that exposure.
So is that the possibility?
Or the next option is that nothing has changed.
Nothing has changed.
You still have that same elevation of aquatoxin A.
Well, then we're back to, well,
could be current, still current exposure.
Could be that you really have
stubborn deep toxic pathways
and it's not allowing you to get rid of that.
You have to still do some investigation
but all those things are possible.
But that's what it would tell us.
Because it's very difficult to know
even if say we do our test on our house
and thought something was positive
and then we do remediation on it.
It's very difficult to know that was I did I get that
just because I had an issue with my house?
Is that mean that's where I got aquatoxin A?
That's just because that was there.
Doesn't mean that's where I got it.
Maybe it was from the peanut butter I was eating.
I don't know.
Maybe it was from going to night church meeting
that I was doing every Wednesday.
I don't know.
Maybe it was from your car.
You know, something you didn't yet yet investigate.
So that's what it would tell you.
Do we need to investigate other things?
And microtoxins are serious things.
You could read on that page
on the microtoxin lab report
all the things that it can cause.
And that's based upon the data that's out there.
So that's based upon published data.
So it's not something to play around with
and not be serious about.
So that's why I suggest if that was positive,
we retest that.
Do we need to retest for glyphosate?
Do we need to retest for toxic tech?
It's not important because those are things
that you only have so much control
over that part of your environment and that exposure.
You should already be organic.
You should already be not spreading your law.
You should already be doing as many lifestyle changes
that you can possibly do.
But we're still being contaminated every single day
by forces that are beyond our control.
But microtoxins are much more within a person's control
limits to a point as the other environmental toxins.
So that's what we do when we do want to retest of data spots.
So I'd say six months.